مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف دائما المحلل
العسكري اللواء فائز الدويري الذي سنتحدث
معه قبل ان نستعرض اخر التطورات الميدانيه
على الخريطه التفاعليه مع سلام خضر شكرا
عبد السلام اذا تطورات متسارعه في قطاع
غزه من شماله الى جنوبه و على اكثر من
مستوى سنبدا من التطورات الابرز في شمال
قطع غزه شمال قطاع غزه القوات الاسرائيليه
كانت تقول على مدى اليومين الماضيين انها
سيطرت على منطقتين اساسيتين على بيت لاهيا
وعلى جباليا بشكل تقريبا شبه كامل وامس
قالت انها ايضا توغلت باتجاه الشجاعيه
اليوم شهدت منطقه جبليا اشتباكات واسعه
بين كتائب القسام وبين الجيش الاسرائيلي
على اكثر من محور وقالت القسام انها اوقعت
خسائر ايضا في جباليا تحديدا قالت كتائب
سرايا القدس انها ب مع كتائب القسام نفذت
عمليه مشتركه في جباليا واستهدفوا فيها
مجموعه من قوات الاحتلال واشتبكوا مع من
بقي من المجموعه حيا بحسب ما قالوا طبعا
هذه الاشتباكات ايضا لم تكن محصوره فقط في
منطقه اقصى شمال قطاع غزه امتدت الى
وسط المنطقه الشماليه تحديدا الى مدينه
غزه هناك في مدينه غزه تطورات على اكثر من
مستوى هذه المره ايضا القوات الاسرائيليه
انسحبت من تل الهواء وايضا انسحبت من
المنطقه المحيطه بتل الهواء بشكل مفاجئ
والاهالي دخلوا ووجدوا فضائع في تلك
المنطقتين هنا هناك اشتباكات كثيفه في هذه
الاثناء تدور في الدرج
والتفاح بحسب ما اعلنت القسام وسرايا
القدس ايضا يشتبكون مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
في هذه المنطقه امس كانت غزه شهدت تفجيرا
عنيفا جدا قالت القوات الاسرائيليه انه
استهدف مركز قياده وانف وشبكه انفاق تابعه
لحركه حماس بالانتقال الى جنوب مدينه غزه
وقرب المحافظه الوسطى هذه المناطق من
الروضه والزهراء والصفاء والبريج هي احدى
او بضعه مناطق طلبت قوات الاحتلال من
المواطنين اخلائها والتوجه بشكل كامل
باتجاه دير البلح علما ان دير البلح تشهد
قصفا اسرائيليا مكثفا اليوم وهناك
شهداء في هذه المنطقه علما انه لا يوجد
مستشفيات بل مراكز طبيه فقط في دير البلح
سنخت من جنوب قطاع غزه جنوب قطاع غزه لا
تزال الاشتباكات مستمره في منطقه خان يونس
مع محاولات اسرائيليه لتطوي بشكل كامل
تقريبا ولكن حتى الان لم تنجح القوات
الاسرائيليه بتطويق منطقه خان يونس ايضا
كان هناك عمليه نفذتها سرايا القدس في
منطقه الزنه وهناك ايضا عمليات نفذتها
كتائب القسام قالت انها استهدفت على الاقل
اربعه جنود واوقعت بين قتلى وجرحه واشتبكت
ايضا مع مع من بقي من القوه الراجله نختم
في مساله واحده وهو ان اليوم اسرائيل
اعلنت انها دفعت بلواء جديد باتجاه منطقه
خانيونس لواء كفير بعد ان انسحبت يوم امس
القوات التابعه للواء جولاني هذه التفاصيل
تحديدا الدفع بلواء خامس الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه نتابعها معك ومع ضيفك عبد السلام
شكرا لك سلام بطبيعه الحال من هذه النقطه
اذا مع انسحاب كتيبه من لواء جولاني يتم
الان ضم كتائب والويه جديده خمسه الويه
سياده اللواء تنشط الان في خان يونس ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك بالنسبه للقوه الاسرائيليه
وانتشارها يعني اول الانسحاب في منطقه في
القطاع القاطع الشمالي وال الحديث عن
التعزيز يقع في القاطع الجنوبي وبالتالي
لابد من الفصل بين المنطقتين الان اي
عمليه دفع قوه اضافيه لانه هناك تعثر في
العمليات في منطقه خانيونس منذ ان بدات
المرحله الثانيه وبدات التوغل من طريق
كيسوفيم الى القراره الى المطاحن الى
ابراج
حمد والانعطاف جنوبا ثم تراجعت كذلك
الجناح الثاني للهجوم كان من الفخاري
ولكنها تعثرت العمليات ولم تستطع ان تصل
الى شارع صلاح الدين وبالتالي كان لابد من
من وجهه نظر للقوات المهاجمه ان تدفع
بقوات اضافيه من اجل تنشيط العمليات
وتحقيق انجازات لانه العمليات متعثره
وخطوط الاشتباك لازالت خصوصا في خان يونس
منطقه شرق خانيونس خان يونس يعني الحديث
عن معركه خان يونس الحقيقيه لم تبدا بعد
هي عمليه محاوله تطويق المدينه من بعد من
اجل قطع طرق الامداد على المقاتلين وعلى
المدينه بصوره كامله لكن القتال لا يزال
يجري بصوره رئيسيه في الزنه بن سهيلا
عبسان الجديده عبسان الكبيره ولم يستطع
الوصول لكن دعني اشير الى النقطه انه
بالامس كان هناك حديث في البدايه عن
انسحاب لواء جولاني ومن ثم العوده والحديث
عن تصحيح الخبر العاجل بكتيبه لكن دعني
القي نظره اي حتى تكون المعركه واضحه
للمشاهد الان الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما قبل
ان يبدا بالعمليه حشد اربعه فرق رئيسيه
وهي الفرقه 80 وهذه الفر الفرقه نشرت لواء
فقط اشترك في العمليات داخل قسي وبقي
ثلاثه الويه منه في غلاف غزه ال اللي هو
اللواء 460 انا هنا اقدم معلومات الفرقه
162 دفعت تنظيمها ثلاث الويه دفعت بثلاثه
الويه وهي جفعاتي
ونحالين احتياط عملياتي اقرب من موقع فرقه
الاحتياط الاستراتيجي لكن تم تجميع قوات
اضافيه ارسلت من المنطقه الوسطى ومن
المنطقه الشماليه المنطقه الوسطى الحقت
لواء المظليين 35 ولواء المظليين احتياط
55 وهذه هي قيادتها في النبي يعقوب اي
والحقت الان كذلك الحقت لواك
ماندز وهو عوز و يعمل في الشجاعيه والحقت
لواء كوماندز 89 ولواء احتياط 55 يعمل في
جباليه في عجاله الفرقه 877 اللي فييه هدا
والسامره الحقت لواء الفرقه 99 الحقت لواء
يفتاح والمنطقه الشماليه الحقت لواء
جولاني فاصبح مجموع الالويه التي تعمل في
هذه المنطقه 16 لواء عندما نقول 16 لواء
الفرقه الاستاندرد العالمي من من من ثلاثه
الى خمسه وبالتالي نتحدث عن خمسه الى سته
فرق تعمل نقطه واحده فيما يتعلق لواء
جفعاتي الذي اثير حوله يوم امس الكثير من
الحم لواء جولاني اثير حوله الكثير من
الحديث هذا اللواء اسس قبل انشاء الكيان
الاسرائيلي وكان يوجد به كتيبتين الكتيبه
12 و13 وهي هذه هي الكتائب الام الحق به
كتيبه مشاء اضافيه والحق به ثلاث كتائب
الدبابات والحق به كتيبتين مدفعيه واسلحه
الاسناد التي انسحبت بالامس هي الكتيبه 13
من 13 وهي التي عانت من اصابات زادت عن
40% من القدره من الموجود
الفعلي الكتيبه لكن في ظل هذه المعلومات
ونتحدث هنا عن عزيمه لدى رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنا من نتنياهو للاستمرار في
الحرب هذا ما اكد عليه في كل تصريحاته
الاخيره رغم الحديث عن محاولات للدخول في
تفاوض لتبادل الاسرى من خلال ما ذكرته انت
ومن خلال هذا المعطى الجديد بان هناك خمسه
الويه تعمل او تنشط في خان يونس كيف
ترى تسيير العمليات من خلال هذه الالويه
وال المعدات العسكر نحن نتحدث عن حرب لا
متناظره حرب غير
تقليديه مفاهيم هذه الحرب مختلفه واليه
تحليلها مختلفه عندما نتحدث عن 15 الى 16
لواء دخلت غلاف غزه مقابل الاف من
المقاتلين لديهم امكانات محدوده بالاسلحه
قصيره المدى اذا هنا انا لا اتوقع معارك
دبابات ضاريه كانها في الا في اليوم
التاسع والعاشر من حرب اكتوبر على في قناه
السويس انا هنا اتحدث عن كم هائل من
المعدات دخل وهناك مقاتلين بادوات بسيطه
يشتبكوا معها من خلال الواقع الميداني لكن
الخلاصه هذه الاليات المعدات التي عبرت
تجاوز الرقم منذ اول
امس حد
الالف قد يحاجج البعض ان ابو عبيده ذكر
720 نعم هو ذكر ما يخص القسام لم يذكر ما
يخص بقيه الفصائل فاصبح الرقم الاجمالي
اكثر من 1000 مع اليه قتال وهذه اليات
الفرقه فيها 350 اليه اذا نتحدث عن معدات
ثلاثه فرق اخرجت من الخدمه وبالتالي نعود
الى الى سؤال او حديث نتنياهو نتنياهو
لديه مبرراته الشخصيه فيما يتعلق بوضعه
اولا والامر الاخر لان المفاوضات يبدو
مغلق دخلت نفق مظلم ونتائجها قد لا تتحقق
فهو يرفع كما يقال العس الغليظه شكرا
جزيلا لك بطبيعه الحال هذا كان الفيديو
لعمليات تمشيط في بيت حانون كما قال
الجانب الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء
فايز الدويري على كل ما تفضلت به